au texas fini le port du masque
cet état du sud des états unis pourtant
lourdement touchés par le virus
avec plus de quarante quatre mille morts
lève des restrictions en place depuis
près de huit mois
le gouverneur greg abbott a annoncé ce
mardi la réouverture totale des
commerces d'ici la semaine prochaine une
décision à contre courant pour ce
territoire qui compte 29 millions
d'habitants près de six mois la plupart
des entreprises sont ouvertes à 75 ou
50% et pendant cette période trop de
texans ont été écartés des possibilités
d'emploi trop de propriétaires de
petites entreprises ont eu du mal à
payer leurs factures
il faut que cela cesse il est maintenant
temps d'ouvrir le texas à 100%
une initiative pourtant loin d'être
isolé aux états unis d'autres états ont
également annoncé la levée des
restrictions tels que le michigan la
louisiane ou encore le mississippi
à chicago les élèves ont retrouvé le
chemin de l'école cette semaine tandis
que les restaurants du massachussets ont
reçu l'autorisation de rouvrir sans
limite de capacité un regain de
confiance outre atlantique liées à la
campagne de vaccination qui bat son
plein dans le pays
ce mardi le président américain joe
biden a tenu un discours optimiste
concernant sa stratégie vaccinale
enfin et je tiens à remercier johnson
johnson et merck d'avoir pris les
devants et d'avoir été de bons citoyens
corporatifs pendant cette crise
nationale
voici ce que tout cela signifie nous
sommes maintenant en bonne voie pour
avoir suffisamment de vaccins pour
chaque adulte en amérique et d'ici la
fin mai un nouveau cap qui se précise
pour les américains alors que joe biden
avait évoqué il y a quelques semaines
l'objectif de vacciner tous les adultes
d'ici fin juillet une accélération de la
campagne que le président explique par
une collaboration historique à propos du
vaccin d'une firme américaine today et
aujourd'hui nous annonçons un grand pas
en avant
les plus grandes entreprises de soins de
santé et pharmaceutique du monde qui
sont généralement concurrentes
travaillent ensemble sur le vaccin
johnson and johnson et merck vont
travailler ensemble pour augmenter la
production du vaccin de johnson and
johnson
c'est le type de collaboration entre
entreprises que nous avons vue pendant
la seconde guerre mondiale deux
avantages conséquents face au vaccin de
johnson johnson
ce dernier ne nécessite qu'une seule
dose est peut-être plus facilement
stockées à des températures de
réfrigérateur pour le moment le groupe
pharmaceutique a certifié l'envoi de 100
millions de doses aux états unis avant
la fin du mois de juin